an Air Force veteran celebrated his
upcoming 90th birthday in midair
Stan Rohr went skydiving recently from a
height of 13,000 feet over California's
Lake Elsinore Stan lost both of his legs
in his 80s but hasn't lost his sense of
adventure
Nicky batiste is here with his story
Nicky it's not exactly your typical 90
year old Anthony Stan Rohr is not one to
act as eight he turns 90 tomorrow but
that's not slowing him down the active
senior competes in sports like tennis
with men half his age so a daring
activity to celebrate as 90th birthday
would be no different you're gonna jump
out of a perfectly good airplane that's
right it's safe to say Stan Rohr is a
risk-taker and just days shy of his
birthday he's jumping into ninety
without looking back my daughter asked
me if I would like to jump with her and
since she was jumping I said yes but
they didn't realize it was going to be
such a production
rawrr jumped 13,000 feet from an
airplane above southern california's
lake elsinore to celebrate turning 90
this week January the 7th 1932 Steve at
7:30
I remember the retired math and physics
teacher took the leap with his daughter
Linda I joked in the beginning I was
like you know what if you're gonna go
it's a good way to go and he's like I'm
not dying I was like okay she says her
dad has been blessed with more energy
than most he can still be - 20 year-old
antennas and it's the will and the
desire and I think that really is an
inspiration to a lot of people roar
regularly hiked mountains but in his 80s
he lost both legs because of blood clots
behind his knees that did the opposite
of slowing him down when you're hanging
out with people that are 4050 years
younger than you are you got to put
forth a little bit of effort Terry the
avid biker wheelchair tennis player and
kayaker modified his truck so he can
drive himself anywhere he uses pulleys
to get his wheelchair in and out and
unloads his kayaks by himself he's an
inspiration livings a choice every day
and I think if you choose that bike
there's a lot you can do moving to us
all aid work says this tops the craziest
things he's done in his life and he
wants to do it again who's in I've done
once I've gone once begged okay yeah age
is only a number when he turned 90 you
can put that number on a yeah I love how
his daughter talks about his will and
desire and they're both extremely
powerful and brave and resilient and
thanks to my sister I love the daughter
wearing a t-shirt that says fearless
Warren
thank you very much
you